in the scene where Dylan Tucker is
securing his family during The Purge we
see him using app-based security
interface the UI is clearly the same as
the interface of the sound and security
system seen back in the first movie
there have been many references to sand
and security since then the company is
never mentioned by name here but it's
clearly supposed to be the same system
to learn some of the interesting Secrets
hidden around the Yeehaw Purge or as you
may know it the forever Purge stick
around to the end of this video
[Music]
they are
I still can't believe they didn't call
that huge Miss DOT the forever Purge
doesn't even make that much sense most
of the characters in the movie call it
the ever after Purge not the forever
Purge so the yee-haw Purge was written
by series Creator James demonico and
directed by everardo Valerio gout who
had mostly worked in TV his previous
film was an award winner at the Mexican
Academy of film so he was probably seen
as a good choice to be able to direct a
movie with scenes that contain both
English and Spanish interchangeably the
use of language actually relates to one
of our things you missed so let's get
into the kosas Que te periste
early in the movie we see the border
wall between the U.S and Mexico which
now blocks citizens from being able to
see into the other country unlike the
current wall which has sleds this was
probably done to increase the feeling of
division and tension between the two
Nations it goes along with the graffiti
scene later build Bridges and not walls
it also allows people to deface the wall
with graffiti and some of which is kind
of impressive this American flag has a
hammer and sickle from the old USSR flag
suggesting that somebody wants to see
the US transition to Communism the
government's empowered during The Purge
movies is the nffa or new founding
fathers of America they are portrayed to
be objectively evil but they are clearly
not the type of evil that subscribes to
Communism for example the nffa thrives
on division between different levels of
income while communism looks to
eliminate the free market entirely so
this symbol suggests the emergence of a
new group which we see before long the
opening titles show animated scenes of
the USA with each becoming corrupted
with red splatters and scary imagery one
of these shows a good old-fashioned
American barbecue when the guests become
corrupted with Purge one of which looks
like Kimmy's mask from The Purge
election year also there's one that I
find funny we see the street front with
shops like Victoria's Bakery and Kyle's
Dress Boutique but when it glitches out
it just becomes Kyle's die now that
sounds like somewhere I would shop we
learned that the nffa has been voted
back into Power again and this is where
I need to pause the analysis for a
little rant last movie chronologically
before the Yeehaw Purge was The Purge
election year where we saw Senator
Charlie Rhone win the election thus
ending the nffa's reign of power but at
the very end there's an uprising
now hearing reports about a few
scattered incidents around the country
where nffa supporters are reacting
violently to this defeat they are
burning cars
attacking police officers and then it
just ends the movie ends then they did a
prequel and then they did two seasons of
the TV series both of which took place
before election year so all this time
we're waiting to see what happened after
the election finally they announced the
the hopperge and it looks like it's
going to be about groups who refuse to
stop purging I thought it was going to
take place right after election year but
it's not it's years later president
round would have been in power from 2040
to 2044. in the US you can serve a
maximum of two four-year terms so if she
was reelected she'd last until 2048. our
only real clue about the dates in the
Yeehaw Purge is this poster for a purge
week Barbecue on Friday March 19th it
doesn't matter if rone served one or two
turns was the first time March 19th
lands on a Friday is the Year 2049. yes
The Purge has now caught up to Blade
Runner and San Francisco Rush the this
is what future Tech looks like in Blade
Runner 2049 here's what it looks like in
The Purge 2049 transportation in Blade
Runner transportation in The Purge I'm
sure the real 2049 will fall somewhere
in between but still we're getting
scammed out of potentially cool sci-fi
elements anyway in America we ended up
not having to wait for The Purge movie
to show us what it looks like when
people refuse to accept losing an
election and that is as much time as I'm
willing to spend on that our main
characters this time are Juan and Adela
who are illegal immigrants looking to
get away from the drug cartel in their
home country we see Adela making great
effort to learn English everything in
their house is labeled with sticky notes
containing both the English and Spanish
word sink dish curtains toaster flower
pot plants television and others she
scolded one for not putting in the same
effort that she does please where are we
you need to practice your English and
she listens to an audio program that
seems to teach her what to say if she
ever gets caught repeat after me I was
just visiting friends in Texas she is
even seen with a book called English
Fast Track learning for Spanish speakers
though it would make more sense if the
title of the book was in Spanish
considering that the target audience
wouldn't understand English until after
reading the book The reason I bring all
of this up is because the language
barrier comes into play at the end when
Adela is captured and forced to call her
people for help in order to lure them
into a trap she called out in Spanish
and he demands she speak English so he
can understand but she refuses as a
result her friends are able to save her
usually in a movie the main character
goes through a character Arc where a
character is one way at the beginning
and undergoes a change that allows him
or her to overcome an obstacle in The
Purge James sandin learns that A
stranger's life is just as valuable as
his family is and gives him a chance to
live in Anarchy Leo Barnes realizes that
revenge on his son's killer will not
make him feel better about the loss
Adela almost has like a reverse
character arm she basically goes back to
the way she was before the movie It
Feels feels kind of backwards Dylan has
a more traditional character at the
beginning he wants his culture to stay
separate from Mexican culture and he's
envious of Juan's Cowboy skills at the
end he has to work together with Juan
and he finds that he is now the one
crossing the border and integrating into
Mexican Society in that sense he's
actually a lot like Leo Barnes and
Anarchy who started off wanting to be a
lone Hunter but ended up being saved by
his new friends there are a lot of loose
homages to previous Purge movies one
example is Chiago harjo early on we see
him on TV preaching the truth about how
the purge is not effective at releasing
anger later on he meets with the main
characters and helps escort them through
danger he's filling the role of Carmelo
Johns and Anarchy or Dante Bishop in
election year the Revolutionary that our
characters see on TV and later meet up
with to receive assistance by the way
his broadcast about how the purge
actually only increases anger and does
not decrease it is an echo of the
research done by Professor Drew Adams in
The Purge season 2. Thiago doesn't
specifically mention Professor Adams but
we can assume that he is referencing her
study which the nffa unsuccessfully
tried to cover up like in past purges
there is a lot more we can learn and
from looking at some of the small
details hidden in graffiti and artwork
around the city
[Music]
The Immigrant character Adela Works in a
butcher shop you may have thought about
how this feels representative of The
Purge which temporarily turns the entire
country into a butcher shop in fact the
logo features two knives coming together
different but also reminiscent of the
Clash of knives seen on the official
nffa seal which first appeared in
Anarchy this idea is further touched
upon at the beginning of the purge as
everyone locks down we cut from the
ranch where all of the cattle are herded
together in the dark to the passengers
on the Bus full of potential Purge
victims it's very symbolic of how human
lives are treated like cattle in this
world the bus by the way says La Mercier
public schools on the side it's named
after one of The Producers Sebastian K
Le Mercier and this isn't the first time
there's been a purge Easter egg to
reference him this right here
is an original La Mercier overall the
nffa takes a backseat this time thanks
to the rise of the radical group the
real Patriots of America I've talked a
lot in my Purge videos about how the
nffa is always associated with the color
blue which matches the color of the blue
batizias in the world of The Purge
people put out these flowers to show
support for The Purge we only see one
example in this movie maybe a sign that
the nffa is losing favor on the contrary
the new Patriots of America logo is red
they probably made that choice so they
can be viewed as enemies of the nffa I
also noticed that the emergency
broadcast screen is red again they've
also reinstated immunity for government
officials ranking 10. guess they didn't
like their president getting killed too
much in election year and decided to
roll that one back we don't see much of
the blue batizias this time but there is
a new flower of importance the red roses
our characters are told to follow the
Roses if they ever get into trouble in
America being red they symbolize safety
whereas the blue flowers symbolize
violence I've talked before about how
this is the opposite of what you'd
expect which is probably why the nffa
chose blue to deceive people these can
be seen throughout the city it's
established that they guide our
characters to safety but what isn't
immediately obvious is how the
directions are hidden into each painting
this one is part of a mural with a
one-way sign telling them to go right
the next one has a grim reaper pointing
to the left this poster shows a Lucha
Libre wrestler pointing up and to the
right the stem of this Rose extends into
an arrow pointing left all of these
signs lead them to the neon Rose at the
end there are other relevant pieces of
Street Arts when everyone arrives at the
safe Zone I noticed artwork of a giant
pair of eyes with a gunshot in between
the purge TV series featured lots of eye
graffiti as a symbol for the nffa's
dystopian surveillance this area is
essentially the new underground triage
center from election year the inner
cutting between it and the more
comfortable conditions of the ranch
family relaxing at home show how the
purge affects different social classes
much more than others an idea that's
been heavy in the series ever since the
first movie it seems that the Florida
man meme is one of the many things that
hasn't changed by 2049 the line that the
broadcaster leaves us with before going
off the air is also a significant
reference good night Texas and good luck
it's a nod to the 2005 movie good night
and good luck good night and good luck
yeah that's the one I talked earlier
about the communist symbol appearing on
the American flag at the border wall
good night and good luck is all about a
group of journalists who try to expose
the truth about American politician
Joseph McCarthy who was making Reckless
and unsubstantiated claims of Communism
around the time of the Cold War the
trailer for good night and good luck
describes America during this period as
a nation terrorized by its own
government certainly not a far cry from
what's going on in The Purge only under
very different circumstances good night
and good luck deals with the Integrity
of the media which is not really an
aspect of this particular Purge film
there's no journalist character in this
movie The only somewhat relevant beat is
when the nffa announces that anyone
displaying the ever after Purge flag
will be arrested immediately which of
course would be unconstitutional in the
United States because it would violate
the freedom of speech a lot like how
McCarthy tried to silence his critics
the journalism aspect might be relevant
if the filmmakers are trying to give
themselves a pat on the back essentially
saying that they're making a brave
statement through their art the last few
Purge films have gotten more and more
pointed towards aspects of the real-life
USA political situation again not really
interested in getting into that so let's
talk about franchise callbacks as this
purge begins we see scenes of purging
happening around the city as we often do
here are a bunch of men tracking victims
with dogs as seen during the Anarchy
this dude gets dragged behind a
motorcycle something we saw in the first
Purge then there's this firing squad set
up right outside of a church the
Firearms go off right as the church
bells strike midnight this is an example
of midnight Purge Mass which we were
first introduced to in The Purge
election year the saddest part about
2049 is not the purge but the fact that
we still don't have protected bike Lanes
get it together America later on there's
also an encounter with this guy with a
swastika on his face it's kind of a
spiritual successor to Earl danzinger
the Neo-Nazi from election year he
refers to the gunshot sounds all around
them as Homegrown Music from the
Heartland I think he's meant to signify
the attitude of some gun enthusiast the
idea that it becomes a recreational
activity like listening to music and
they may lose sight of how dangerous
these weapons actually are we meet this
guy inside the police fan which is
rounding up Ever After purgers in
typical Purge fashion this van gets
rolled over that's basically a tradition
at this point in the franchise it
happened in election year and in season
two one tradition they seemed not to
uphold however was having a character
named Sabian then there's this
yes they really did try to make a jump
scare out of literally just a horse
walking LOL then we've got my favorite
guy his name's Kirk
then there are some not so great guys
like this man in a high Vis vast not
exactly great for sneaking around during
The Purge he also uses a mallet as his
weapon even though it seems very easy to
get guns in this world guess this dude's
playing on hard mode as were the
motorcyclists who thought they could
challenge a big truck not a battle
you're gonna win the characters realize
their best bet is to seek Asylum by
crossing the border back into Mexico I'm
not going to talk about the Dracula
Frankenstein and psycho appearances
because they're not even references
they're just there but 99k USD is a damn
good deal for a luxury condo especially
considering inflation by 2049. what a
deal I wonder if you can walk from there
to the festival in Central Park
bettercheck website.com to find out one
of the things I like to do is scan all
of the graffiti in The Purge films and
see if there's anything interesting
written in my video on Anarchy I talked
about how they took a shot at Hollywood
film producer David neustader by making
a man named David newstatter be one of
The Purge victims found in the Street in
this one there's a message that reads
kill David dead there's probably no
connection but if there is wow they're
still not over this are they the mystery
deepens anyway the Native American
Chiago is going to help them get across
the border but not before we stumble
upon a few more eye-opening details
an interesting detail about the finale
is that the forever purgers don't need
masks anymore but a couple of them
continue to wear them anyway I think
it's generally accepted that the purpose
of the mass is to hide the purger's
identities because after The Purge you
got to go back to work and even people
that participated are ashamed but with
the ever after Purge they aren't
planning on ever going back to normal
perhaps some were confident that it
really would last forever While others
were not but they do have these hats
though how much you want to bet these
are the same hats that they gave the
cast and crew we hear a new chance from
The purgers Purge
after
actually it's more of a Twist on an old
classic we first heard chance of purge
and purify in election year these
anti-nffa radicals have taken a motto
from the nffa and twisted it into
something of their own I think it's
meant to be a parallel to groups that
latch onto one political idea and fester
into their own little Cults or whatever
the battle rages on this guy
in The Legend of Zelda game with the
bomber
this is our characters get closer to the
border the purgers close in on that
there's a Wilhelm scream
if you aren't familiar The Wilhelm
scream is a funny sound effect found in
many many movies usually when a
character falls down or gets shot or
something it's named after a character
named private Wilhelm from the 1953
Western film the charge at feather river
which used it over and over
you can find compilations on YouTube
that show just how many movies shows and
games just sampled the sound so I was
absolutely shocked that this is the
first Wilhelm scream that I pointed out
on things you missed I guess it kind of
makes sense it's a very silly sound
effect so it's probably not that likely
to be used in horror movies this is a
horror Channel I guess it's fitting that
the sound became famous in a western and
I'm introducing it in this Purge movie
with Western elements we should start a
Wilhelm counter
we'll see if we ever revisit that anyway
the characters make it across the border
and Dylan and Cassie are able to safely
have their baby
you want to hold your daughter I'm sorry
what what the [ __ ] is going on here do
they not know how this works did they
just run out of pink hats how do you run
out of pink hats this was supposed to be
the last movie in the franchise but it
answers nothing and it really just
raises more questions in fact the first
thing we hear during the credits is this
isn't over what will the new American
look like when this all ends
it wasn't long before James demonico
suddenly had an idea for a new Purge
movie and reportedly it went into
development it's pretty clear now that
we were lied to about The ehaw Purge
being the last movie but honestly I'm
kind of glad this next one will
allegedly bring Frankie Grillo back he's
the guy that plays Leo Barnes that's
something that I wanted for this movie
and it wouldn't be right to close things
out without a proper conclusion to the
Leo Barnes Trilogy I'd also like to see
the adults Charlie sandin the kid from
the first one he'd be in his 40s now
he's a character who lived most of his
life in The Purge era lost his father in
The Purge at a very young age and has
been shown to be selfless the last time
that we met it he could be a useful
character to turn to as the country
continues to fall apart as for villains
Joe Owens and godhead 2.0 from the TV
series are as far as we know still alive
they are among the most powerful
villains that we've ever seen and they
could easily be side villains that work
alongside one final threat I'm probably
hyping this up too much we'll probably
just get Frank Grillo but when The Purge
returns so will I with another episode
of things you missed click the playlist
on the left for all of my Purge analyzes
and remember to subscribe to Easy's
world for new Horrors every week ring
the death bell and select all
notifications and I will see you in the
next one assuming we both survived
[Music]